ja mein vortrag knüpft direkt an
denjenigen von herrn buchheim an indem
er kann's gedanken über das böse zum
ausgangspunkt nimmt
worin liegt nach kannte grund des bösen
wir hatten jetzt was gehört ganz
allgemein über den vernunft ursprung des
bösen
ich knüpfe daran jetzt direkt an mit
einem zitat besitzt die tat 1 auf dem
textblatt weder die natürlichen triebe
des menschen noch seine vernunft können
ein erklärungs grund des bösen abgeben
ich lese es nur vor dass erkannt um also
einen grund des moralisch bösen im
menschen anzugeben enthält die
sinnlichkeit also die neigungen triebe
zu wenig denn sie macht den menschen
indem sie die triebfedern die aus der
freiheit entspringen können wegnimmt zu
einem bloß tierischen eine vom
moralischen gesetze aber frei sprechend
gleichsam boshafte vernunft ein
schlechthin böser wille enthält dagegen
zu viel weil dadurch der widerstreit
gegen das gesetz selbst zur triebfeder
denn ohne alle triebfeder kann die will
kündigt bestimmt werden erhoben und so
das subjekt zu einem teuflischen wesen
gemacht würde keines von beiden aber ist
auf den menschen anwendbar
dieses zitat ist der ausgangspunkt für
meinen vortrag kant hatte deswegen weil
er sagte dass wir keine böse vernunft
boshafte 5 haben können als menschen
davon gesprochen dass die freiheit zum
bösen an unvermögen ist was jetzt genau
das unvermögen ist ob es nur was privat
iwes ist oder ob es ein unvermögen ist
ein vermögen zum bösen im schwachen
sinne oder nur eine schwäche ein
erliegen an willensschwäche das ist
offen jedenfalls sagt er sein unvermögen
können wir das böse um des bösen tun
gibt es eine boshafte vernunft wie genau
ist unsere freiheit zum bösen zu
verstehen
ein bloßer mangel an guten oder an sein
die klassische präventions- theorie wird
dem phänomen nicht gerecht wir aber hat
dann eine positive theorie des bösen aus
zu sehen die die aktivität des
individuums im akt des bösen ernst nimmt
können wir das böse um des bösen willen
wollen ähnlich wie kant von vermögen
gibt es nicht sei es auch fichte der die
möglichkeit einer boshaften von bestritt
dass die zitat 2 es ist schlechthin
unmöglich und widersprechend dass jemand
bei dem deutlichen bewusstsein seine
pflicht im augenblicke des handels mit
gutem bewusstsein sich entschließe seine
pflicht nicht zu tun dass er gegen das
gesetz sich empörend ihm den gehorsam
verweigere und sich zur maxime machen
muss mache nichts zu tun was seine
pflicht ist darum weil es seine pflicht
ist eine solche maxime wäre
teuflisch habe der begriff des teufels
widerspricht sich selbst und hebt sich
so nach auf inwiefern liegt darin ein
widerspruch wichtig scheint unter dem
guten bewusstsein nicht das gute
gewissen zu verstehen sondern eher so
etwas wie klarer verstand
nun ist es nach fichte bereits
begrifflich ausgeschlossen dass der
mensch durch das vermögen welches ihm
die normativität der moral vor hält
seine vernunft gegen das sind dasselbe
handelt noch ein zitat von fichte es
wären sie nach in demselben momente
durch dasselbe vermögen in ihm
widersprechende forderungen welche
voraussetzungen sich selbst vernichtet
und der klarste offenbar erste
widerspruch ist so etwas wie eine
boshafte vernunft ist nach fichte wie
auch nach kant grundsätzlich für den
menschen ausgeschlossen
eine vernünftige zugleich gebietet was
gut ist und den grund für das
zuwiderhandeln gegen ihr gebot in sich
birgt würde sich der meinung von fichten
von kant selbst aufheben
in meinem vortrag wende ich mich jetzt
drei nach kantischen denkern zu die die
freiheit des bösen um der bösartigkeit
willen philosophisch oder ästhetisch
weiter zu bestimmen suchten als es kant
und fichte getan hatten
da sich der versuch die perversion der
vernunft das böse um des bösen willen zu
tun mit vernünftigen mitteln
darzustellen als aussichtslos erweist
verwenden alle drei denker schelling
kirche und edgar allan poe den ich noch
mit aufzunehmen
metaphern und ästhetische
darstellungsformen
die natürlichen rationalen grund haben
aber das an das veranschaulichen und das
phänomen in seiner paradoxen struktur
darzustellen diese drei denken nach kant
versuchen eine solche boshafte vernunft
zu denken
dies ist mit den mitteln der vernunft
freilich schwer möglich deswegen
verwenden sie bilder und wie eine kuh es
tut poetische beschreibungen
interessant ist dabei dass alle drei
denker auf den begriff des geistes
rekurrieren
und zwar in der mehrdeutigkeit des
deutschen begriffs geist also reist hat
diverse bedeutung kann das geistige das
mentale man kann aber auch ein dämon
main ein diamond kann aber auch so was
wie beschwingtheit stimulierung bedeuten
und in diesem sinne dieser
vieldeutigkeit von geistigkeit die immer
noch eine gewisse rationale struktur hat
versuchen diese drei dinge so meine
these diese boshafte vernunft zu denken
eine struktur die sich zeigen möchte
reflexiv zur vernunft verhält und
zugleich diese übersteigt sich daran
aber auch zu ästhetik hin öffnet
beginnen möchte ich aber nicht mit
schelling soll mit einem weniger
bekannten denker und schriftsteller
nämlich mit karl philipp moritz der im
zweiten stück des ersten bandes seines
magazins zur erfahrung seelenkunde aus
dem jahr 1783 also noch bevor kann seine
moral philosophischen hauptwerke
geschrieben hat unter dem titel eigener
erfahrung über willensfreiheit folgendes
bekennt muss man schon fast sagen
zitat 3 ich stand verschieden mal auf
einem hohen turm wo mir das geländer bis
an die brust ging und ich also fort dem
herabstürzen völlig gesichert war
dem ungeachtet aber fiel mir plötzlich
ein schrecklicher gedanke ein wie wenn
ich mich notwendig gedrungen fühlte oben
auf den rand des geländes zu steigen und
so herunter zu springen
es wurde weiter nichts erfordert als
mein wille dieses vorhaben nicht ins
werk zu richten und doch erfüllte mich
dieser gedanke mit schaudern und
ersetzen
es war als ob ich meine eigenen
willensfreiheit nicht traute oder mich
von meinem eigenen willen fürchtete
ich konnte den zustand keine minute
länger ertragen und musste schnell
herabsteigen
ebenso ging es mir in jüngeren jahren
zuweilen in der kirche wo ich warum ich
mir das aussehen und die unordnung
lebhaft vorstellte die daraus entstehen
würde wenn ich mitten während der
predigt anfing laut zu reden
auf einmal war mir so als würde ich laut
reden müssen
ich war darüber in der entsetzlichsten
furcht und dieser gedanke quälte mich
oft die ganze predigt über soviel zu den
bekenntnissen von dem pianisten karl
philipp moritz folgt kant der ja auch
statistisch beeinflusst waren ich komme
jetzt zum zweiten punkt schellings
begriff des bösen schelling hat in
seinen untersuchungen über das wesen der
menschen freiheit den versuch
unternommen die möglichkeit und
wirklichkeit unserer individuellen
entscheidungsfreiheit dh der willkür
oder dem vermögen zum bösen konsistent
zu denken und dazu den rahmen des trans
zentralen idealismus seiner früh
schriften verlassen
ein solcher freiheitsbegriff wie
schelling in denkt aufs engste mit der
individuellen personen bzw
der persönlichkeit wie schellings in den
zusammen wir sie auch in technologischer
umkehr von der kantischen
begrifflichkeit nennt weil bekannte
persönlichkeiten die kritik der
praktischen vernunft das universelle ist
die allgemeine reihe praktischer 50
gerade nicht die individualität im
gegensatz zum tier ist das verhältnis
von eigen und universal will so ist der
mensch nach schelling zusammengesetzt
der eigene wille dass derzeit die das
individuum der universal wille das wäre
vergleichbar mit kants theorie der
vernunft erfasst das jetzt aber volition
ahl schelling ist dieses verhältnis und
gegensatz zum tier beim menschen kein
star sondern ein flexibles der mensch
ist nicht nur seine natur sondern
befindet sich in einem freien verhältnis
dazu
das heißt er hat seine natur und zwar so
zitat dass der mensch das ewige bande
kräfte willkürlich zerreißen kann
zitat schelling schelling bezeichnet
diese reflexive verwobenheit des eigenen
willens mit dem universal
in technologische kontinuität zu
augustinus und leibnitz als geist ist
ganz interessant zitat vier dadurch aber
dass die selbst heißt ist ist sie
zugleich aus dem kreatürlichen ins über
kreatürliche gehoben sie ist will er
sich selbst in der völligen freiheit
erblickt nicht mehr werkzeug das in der
natur schaffen den universal willens
sondern über und außer alle natur ist
der geistigen wille kann sich durch
seine außer und übernatürlich existenz
anders als das tier reflexiv zum
allgemeinen willen verhalten erkannt
dies aber nur mittels des allgemeinwohls
der mensch vermag sich also dem
allgemeinen als sein werkzeug zu
entziehen und die ursprüngliche ordnung
umzukehren also noch ein zitat schelling
das geistige in sich zum mittel zu
machen
im gegensatz zu zum tier ist der mensch
also nicht ein bloßes objekt des
universal willens sondern der
universiade ist selbst objekt der
menschlichen freiheit durch dieses
reflexive verhältnis zum allgemeinen
will stellt der mensch nicht nur wie das
tier besondere sondern vielmehr geistige
das heißt individuelle allgemeinheit da
schwingt trug dieses reflexive
verhältnis der geistigen individualität
der person zur universal willen
metaphorisch so aus das zitat der geist
über dem licht steht die individuelle
persönlichkeit kann sich in cannes
tischer terminologie gesprochen frei zu
allgemein und objektiven vernunft
verhalten und steht insofern über ihr
als sie gebrauch von ihr machen kann
wie aber lässt sich das komplexe
verhältnis von eigen und universal
wieder in der individuellen person
freiheits theoretisch nach schilling
weiter bestimmen
während das im grunde so sagt schelling
bleibende tier durch sein dem
allgemeinen willen untergeordneten
eigenwillen nur willens tendenzen erster
stufe auszubilden vermag also im besten
fall nur aktions freiheit besitzt vermag
die geistige person durch ihre freie
verbindung mit dem allgemeinen willen
sich zu ihren willens tendenzen erster
stufe zu verhalten und höher stufige
koalitionen auszubilden geistigkeit
lässt sich somit als diejenige ebene von
volition zweiter stufe bezeichnen mit
hilfe derer sich die person normativ
positionieren kann indem sie die
relative identität von eigen und und
thalwil gewichtet es ist dabei zu
betonen dass geistigkeit nach schelling
nicht nur auf mobilität eingeschränkt
ist sondern sich in jeder praxis des
individuums als ausdruck seiner
individualität manifestiert position
zweiter stufe sind nicht im sinne eines
allgemein gesetzes dem kantischen
sittengesetz etwa zu verstehen sondern
im sinne des gebrauchs dieses allgemein
willens der von dem eigenwillen
vollständig durchwirkt ist
persönlichkeit ist wie shining prägnant
formuliert zitat die zur geistigkeit
erhobene selbst halte das geistige der
person ist deswegen im grunde auch hier
individueller ausdruck und charakter als
solche geistig existenz ist die
persönlichkeit nicht ein ontologisch auf
derselben ebene wie eigen und universal
während vorhandenes drittes prinzip sind
eine besondere art der verbindung und
modifikation beide prinzipien dergestalt
dass der eigene wille durch momente des
allgemein willens angereichert wird und
sich so zum allgemeinwissen verhalten
kann eine trennung vom universellen vom
universalen bedeutet für ein geistiges
individuum ab nun aber nicht dass der
eigene wille wieder seine reflexivität
verlöre und zurück viele auf die stufe
von bloßen wünschen erster stufe so wäre
nichts anderes als unreflektiertes
begehren filme ist dem individuum durch
die verbindung mit dem universal will
ein für alle mal seine freiheit
angesteckt der mensch verliert diese
nicht mehr selbst wenn er sich vom
universal wird bewusst trend ja das
bewusste trennen vom universalen beweist
gerade seine freiheit des geistes als
ein subjektiver modus des universal
willens nämlich als sein gebrauch wie
ist dieser gebrauch nur näher zu
bestimmen im gegensatz zu kant der die
freiheits entscheidung in seiner
religion schriftführer vor schlicht
gehalten hatte und nur zitat durch treue
beobachtung der phänomene des sittlichen
urteils auf einen subjektiven aller in
die sinne fallenden tat vorangehenden
grund der menschlichen handlungen zitat
kann gestoßen war dann in einem
allgemeinen intelligenz charakter des
menschen zugerechnet werden konnte will
stellen gerade untersuchen zitat wie nun
im einzelnen menschen die entscheidung
für böses oder gut
vorgehe es geht also schelling im
ausgang von kant gerade darum die
gründung eines individuellen personalen
charakters verständlich zu machen
schellings begriff des bösen gewinnt
seinen profilen abgrenzung von
traditionellen theorien der prävention
aber auch von spezifischen neuzeitlichen
vorstellungen des bösen ist exakt die
auf einen philanthrop ismus zurückgehen
und deren letzte konsequenz nachstellen
gar die leugnung des bösen ist das zitat
fünf unteren teil wo mir schelling sehr
modern zu sein scheint weil wir genau
diese tendenz auch immer wieder
beobachten
diese auffassung des bösen zur folge so
schelling besteht der einzige grund des
bösen in der sinnlichkeit oder in der
anime täter nach zitat die freiheit in
der bloßen herrschaft des intelligent
prinzips über die sinnlichen begierden
und neigung besteht und das gute aus
reiner vernunft kommt wonach es
begreiflicherweise für das böse keine
freiheit gibt in dem hier die sinnlichen
neigungen vorherrschen und wodurch so
schelling das böse völlig aufgehoben
wird
das böse schelling wird aber nie ohne
eigene tat vollbracht es besteht darin
dass der eigene wille danach strebt wie
schon gesagt das was er nur in der inter
identität mit dem universal wählen ist
als partikular wille zu sein und noch
ein zitat das eigene prinzip vom
allgemeinen entscheiden will
ein zustand den schelling den geist der
zwietracht nennt und damit signalisiert
dass sich auch in dieser umkehrung der
ordnung immer noch um eine freie und
selbst wusste aktion handelt das
moralisch gute hingegen besteht darin
dass noch ein zitat schelling der eigene
wille des menschen als zentral will im
grunde bleibt so dass das göttliche
verhältnis der prinzipien besteht eine
ordnung die schelling komplementär als
geist der liebe charakterisiert wie
lässt sich das positive wirken des bösen
als geistiges synthese nachstellen
genauer verstehen das böse so schelling
zitat kommt nicht aus der endlichkeit an
sich sondern aus der zum selbst sein
erhobenen endlichkeit
da auch das böse eine geistige struktur
besitzt besteht es in der erhebung des
eigenen willens die zum ziel hat durch
den allgemein wählen
das verhältnis der prinzipien umzukehren
also hier ist die perversion ganz
deutlich um so noch ein zitat ein
eigenes und absonderliches leben zu
formieren oder zusammenzusetzen
das ist ein zitat schellings also
zusammensetzen heißt es ist synthetisch
da ist eine aktivität am werk stellen
charakterisiert diesen positiven zustand
des bösen als einen noch ein zitat
eigenes aber falsches leben ein leben
der lüge ein gewächse unruhe und der
verderbnis es ist im gegensatz zum guten
als einem einigen ganzen ein zertrennt
des ganzes so viel ist denn der willens
aktivität der wehr auch falschen
einheits bildung einen moment nach
schilling der positivität angelegt
werden spricht auch davon dass ihm das
im bösen ein wesen sein muss als die
ganz klare abgrenzung von einer
prävention story in seinen aktiven
missbrauch der freiheit kann das böse
als eine sich behauptete unordnung
geschrieben werden und gleicht damit
einer krankheit die einen organismus
befallen hat und durch diesen existiert
also krankheit hier auch nicht jetzt in
privat even sinne zu verstehen sondern
eben wie auch herr bucher mit seinem
schilling kommentar gezeigt hat er als
ein krebsgeschwür als ein wucherndes
eine wuchernde struktur die durchaus
eine positive art hat auch wenn sie
angewiesen ist auf eine ihr fremde basis
die freiheit des individuums die durch
die trennung des eigenen willens vom
universalen ermöglicht wird besitzt
immer schon eine verlockung eines
schelling sagt soll die situation des
grundes oder eine zitat sechs lust am
kreativen geschenkt sagt wie den und
jetzt kommts welchen auf einem hohen und
jenen gipfel schwindel erfasst gleichsam
eine geheime stimme zu rufen scheint das
eher herabstürzen
eine gewisse ähnlichkeit zu karl philipp
moritz zu seinem turm erlebnis ist hier
gegeben vielleicht hat in ställen
gelesen das müsste ich mal nachforschen
das böse besteht demnach auch nicht
empfehlen von rationalität sondern in
deren geschicktem ausnützen wodurch es
gegenüber dem guten geradezu als eine
erweiterte form von rationalität gelten
darf noch ein zitat schelling der
verstand gibt das prinzip des bösen her
denn er enthält in sich den grund der
zulassung des bösen so dass das böse
tat sich oft mit einer vortrefflichkeit
der einzelnen kräfte vereinigt zeigt die
viel seltener das gute begleitet das
kann auch ein grund dafür sein dass in
kirchen das böse mehr platz geboten wird
in darstellung und sonstigen
literarischen zeugnissen oder böse
ereignen sich nach schelling innerhalb
derselben geistige struktur
sie unterscheiden sich nicht durch ihre
elemente sondern durch deren verbindung
damit sie tat das wenige was durch den
willen der kreatur böse wird ist an sich
selbst das gute das gute ist demnach
nicht die aufgegebene selbst haid durch
das prinzip des allgemein willens
vielmehr bleibt es so schelling der
potenz nach als überwältigt durch
dasselbe im guten auch immer
fortbestehen es ist nicht resignativ
aufgegebene sondern aktiv untergeordnete
selbst zeit die durch den geist
aktivierte selbst hat so schelling wird
demnach im guten nicht niedergeschlagen
und im sinne der weg räumung eines
hindernisses zu kant beseitigt wie der
eigentümer in kants konzeption einer
autonomie der vernunft sondern nur
aufgehoben das heißt in einen anderen
modus versetzt man sie teilt von
schelling ein gutes ohne wirksame selbst
hat ist selbst ein unwirksames gutes ich
komme zur kirche gehört zum zweiten teil
wie bei schelling so hängt auch bei vier
gebäude begriff des bösen aufs engste
mit der metaphysischen bestimmung des
menschen zusammen so bestimmt hier gott
den menschen als ein geistiges wesen
dezidiert geistig für der verdacht zwei
entgegengesetzte prinzipien konstitutiv
sind der geist oder das selbst ist nach
kicker zitat 7 1 verhältnis da sich zu
sich selbst verhält oder ist dasjenige
am verhältnis dass das verhältnis sich
zu sich selbst verhält dass selbst ist
nicht das verhältnis sondern dass das
verhältnis sich zu sich selbst verhält
der mensch ist eine synthese von
unendlichkeit und endlichkeit von
zeitlichem und ewigen von freiheit und
notwendigkeit kurz eine synthese dieser
grundkonstellation des menschen ist in
auffälliger metaphorischer nähe zur
schellings bestimmung der freiheit die
möglichkeit des bösen angelegt die sich
im phänomen der angst
nach kirche konkret weiter erschließen
ist zitat acht angst lässt sich mit
schwindel vergleichen kommt jemand
dahinter seinen augen eine gähnende
tiefe sagt schon zweimal tiefe gehabt
und das sieht so wird ihm schwindelig
aber was ist der grund es ist eben so
sein auge wie der abgrund denn gesetzt
hätten nicht hinunter gstaad
so ist die angst der schwindel der
freiheit der aufkommt wenn der geist die
synthese setzen will und die freiheit
nun ihre eigene in ihre eigene
möglichkeit hinunter blickt und dann die
endlichkeit ergreift um sich daran
festzuhalten
in diesem schwindel sinkt die freiheit
nieder die moralisch qualifizierte
selbst reflexivität anleihen macht
jedoch noch nicht die ganze relationale
verfassung des menschen als geistes aus
als ein selbstreflexive verhältnis zwei
diametral entgegengesetzter prinzipien
steht das selbst zugleich im verhältnis
zu seinem grund sofern es sich nicht
selbst erschaffen hat diesen grund des
selbstbestimmt hier geboren als coach
und reichert damit in moral
philosophischen begriff des bösen um die
theologische dimension der sünde an also
kommt eine zusätzliche relationen diese
ehe schon sehr komplexe struktur des
geistes aus der struktur dieses
komplexen verhältnisses des menschen
kann das wesen der sünde bestimmt werden
sie ist ganz normal gesprochen nach
schild nach kirche gok ein
missverhältnis im zitat sünde ist vor
gott oder mit der vorstellung von gott
verzweifelt nicht man selbst sein zu
wollen oder verzweifelt man selbst sein
zu wollen
die sünde ist demnach potenzierte
schwäche oder potenzierter trotz die
sünde ist die potenzierung der
verzweiflung was eine bestimmung der
sünde als eines um eine weitere
relationale dimension erweitert
inbegriff des bösen trends grenzt sich
kirchen von der antiken tradition ab die
seiner ansicht nach ihre wurzeln bei
sokrates hat und er zur folge das böse
in einem kognitiven defizit besteht
darin liegt nach togo aber gerade ein
problem denn dann stellt sich für die
frage nach dem zurechenbaren grund
dieser unwissenheit die häufig sokrates
und platon dieser ansicht nach im falle
des bösen angesetzt hat
dagegen argumentiert argumentieren
kirkegaard dass die sünde als sünde nur
dann eintreten kann
werden sie mit bewusstsein verbunden ist
gregor führt also die sokratische
argumentation durch eine immanente
kritik hat absurder nach der tat ist
nämlich die sünde unwissenheit so
existiert ja die sind ja eigentlich
nicht denn die sünde ist ja gerade
bewusstheit bedeutet die sünde dass man
das richtige nicht kennt so dass man
deshalb das falsche tut es existiert die
sünde nicht der grund der unwissenheit
kann nur nach dem willen liegen noch in
der tat die frage die sich stellen
müsste ist die nach dem verhältnis von
erkenntnis und will zueinander auf alles
derartige und hier könnte man nun viele
tage weiter fragen lässt sich die
sokratische definition nicht ein
ich kann es dann aber geschehen dass der
mensch willentlich wissentlich sündigt
es ist nach kicker unwahrscheinlich das
zitat der wille hingeht und das
gegenteil von dem tun was die erkenntnis
eingesehen hat dass streng geheim
dafür aber ist es möglich dass
erkenntnis durch zeitlichen aufschub
will endlich verdunkelt wird noch ein
zitat der villa lässt dann einige zeit
vergehen
es entsteht ein interim das heißt wir
wollen es doch bis morgen überlegen
bei all dem wird die erkenntnis dunkler
und dunkler und das niedere gewinnt mehr
und mehr die oberhand
die will ich kann also nach kirche die
vernunft beeinflussen noch ein zitat
allmählich hat der wille nichts dagegen
dass das geschieht er drückt fast ein
auge zu und wenn dann die erkenntnis
gehörig verdunkelt ist dann verstehen
erkenntnis und will sich besser
schließlich sind sie ganz einer meinung
denn nun ist die erkenntnis zur seite
des willens übergegangen und erkennt
dass es ganz richtig ist wie er es will
also wille unvernunft sind nach kirche
kommen an reflexiven verhältnis
zueinander positioniert
an dieser kritik der antiken tradition
zeigt sich das ticket anschluss an
schädigen eine positive und perverse
theorie des bösen vertritt für ihn gilt
zitat das die sünde keine negation
sondern eine position ist dieses
positive der sünde besteht gegenüber dem
bösen nicht darin gegen die moralische
normen zu verstoßen sind dass sie vor
gott geschieht
auch ist die sünde kein einmaliges
punktuelles ereignis sondern die kirche
gesagt
deponieren de kontinuierlich kite die
sünde gehorcht einer anderen logik als
dem gedanken von positiven und negativen
werten die sich auf addieren lassen was
man sie tat der zustand in der sünde ist
im tiefsten sinne die sünde die
einzelnen sünden sind nicht die
fortsetzung der sünde sondern der
ausdruck für die fortsetzung der sünde
jedoch ist die sünde als eine art
lebensform zu verstehen die den ganzen
charakter des menschen fundiert und über
die zeit aufrecht erhält
deshalb ist die sünde die kicker sagt
etwas konsequentes und diese konsequenz
ist sich ist in sicht des bösen hat sie
auch eine gewisse kraft gegner
bezeichnet einen solchen konzeptes
sündhaften menschen als dämonischen
menschen die dämonische mensch will sein
böses wesen um jeden preis auf erhalten
und vor dem einfluss des guten bewahren
da die sünde sein fundament bildet er
ihr seine existenz verdankt zitat gerade
weil der dämonische mensch konsequenz in
sich in der konsequenz des bösen ist
gerade deshalb hatte auch eine totalität
zu verlieren
ich komme jetzt zum schluss und seinem
ausblick auf edgar allan poe von der
philosophie zu ästhetik des bösen soll
es im wert von edgar allan poe findet
sich eine intensive literarische
auseinandersetzung und kann auch sagen
poetologische auseinandersetzung mit dem
phänomen des bösen dass sie nicht mehr
im dienst der moral steht sondern voller
ästhetischer autonomie besitzt power
entwickelt darin damit gewissermaßen
eine perversion poetologie die zentrale
einsichten von schelling aufnimmt den er
nachweislich gekannt hat und auf den er
sich an vier stellen in seinem werk
bezieht also die beziehung ist
nachgewiesen
im post kurz erzählung dem taufte
pervers deutsch der geist der weisheit
wieder geist wird das böse als ein zitat
paradoxes etwas und als perversität
bezeichnet als solche entziehen sich die
phänomene unseren gewöhnlichen verstand
denn ihr grund besteht gerade darin böse
zu handeln weil dieses handeln böse ist
jetzt kommt ein längeres zitat 9
dass also ein langes poetologische zitat
von police vor bei der erforschung der
neigen und triebe der prima mobilia der
menschen ziele haben die psychologen
jetzt einen hang übergangen der obwohl
er sichtbar und deutlich als erstes
ursprünglich nur auf sich selbst zurück
führt zu führen das gefühl vorhanden ist
auch von den moralisten ihren vorgängern
übersehen wurde
wir haben wir alle haben ihn durch die
törichte anmaßung unseres verstandes und
aufmerksam gemacht nie beachtet er
selbst der möglichkeit gedanke ist uns
nie gekommen weil wir das bedürfnis
nicht füllten die tatsache je nach
neigung jenes hannes festzustellen eine
induktion aproz theorie wird die
psychologen zu der einsicht gebracht
haben dass sie als ein primitives
prinzip menschlichen handelns ein
paradoxes etwas annehmen müssten dass
wir in ermangelung eines
charakteristischen aus tricks mit dem
bösen krankhaften kurz mit perversität
bezeichnen wollen
in meinem sinne ist sie in der tat ein
mobile ohne motiv ein nicht motiviertes
motiv und im englischen steht motiviert
also deutscher bezug unter ihrem
einfluss handeln wir ohne verständlichen
zweck oder sollte man dies für einen
widerspruch im ausdruck halten wir
handeln aus dem grunde weil wir nicht
handeln sollten
ich bin meines lebens ebenso gewiss wie
der richtigkeit der behauptung dass das
böse der sündhaft oder schädlich in
irgendeiner handlung oft die
unwiderstehliche macht ist die uns
zwingt allein zwingt die selbe zu
begehen und diese zügellose hang das
böse und des bösen willen zu tun spottet
jeder analyse jeder auflösungen tiefer
liegende elemente ist ein radikaler
primäre elementare beweggrund die
möglichkeit das böse und des bösen
willen zu tun hat die kant noch als
unmöglich verworfen das da dies einem
nur teuflischen wesen wie kann sagte
möglich sein
dagegen argumentiert dieses motiv seien
ganz allgemeiner radikaler primäre
elementare beweggrund den hang zum bösen
bereits kann zugestand und moral
philosophisch thematisiert hatte
analysiert po nun phänomenologische
theologisch eingehender indem er ihn mit
der leidenschaft eines menschen der am
abgrund am rande eines abgrundes
erschaudern steht und sind sich hinein
zu stürzen vergleich dieses zitat 10 und
hier haben wir wieder eine nähe zur
schelling zur kirche und auch zu karl
philipp moritz 13 wir stehen am rande
eines
grundes wir starren in den schlund es
wird uns übel und schwindlig unsere
erste bewegung war für die gefahr
zurückzuweichen unerklärlicherweise
bleiben wir allmählich verschmelzen
unser über befinden unter schwindel
unsere angst mama schelling in einen
nebel half tätiger ein lebhaftes nicht
zu benennen das gefühl nach und nach
unbemerkt unbemerkt man nimmt der nebel
gestalt an wie sich aus dem wäldchen
aussehender bekannten flasche in tausend
und eine nacht der geist bild aber aus
unserer wolke am rande des abgrundes
bildet sich und wird immer greifbarer
eine gestalt die hundertmal schreckhafte
ist als irgendein dämon oder geist der
fabel
und doch ist es nur ein gedanke der das
mag in unseren gebeinen gefrieren macht
und mit wüsten entzündungen schüttelt
prüfen wir solche und ähnliche
handlungsweisen
so finden wir dass sie einzig und allein
dem geiste der perversität entstammen
wir begehen dieselben nur weil wir
fühlen dass wir sie nicht begehen
sollten darüber hinaus oder dahinter
fehlt jeder beweggrund die von po
beschriebenen phänomene des schwindels
und der angst beweisen im grunde auf die
menschliche freiheit es nicht zum bösen
entscheiden zu können
die poetologische möglichkeit einer
teuflischen natur wird auch wenn sie
philosophisch als widersprüchlich
erscheint aus dichtung zur politischen
realität von dieser politischen realität
des bösen um des bösen willens handelt
auch sein im jahr 1843 erschiene
kurzgeschichte der black cat der
schwarze kater
darin beschreibt der anfangs als
treusorgende und tier liebender ehemann
dargestellt aber bald durch trunksucht
zunehmend geschwächte protagonist einen
geist der perversität spirit of
perversen es in sich verspürt den dazu
verleitet böse um des bösen willen zu
handeln
grundlos sticht er seine katze zunächst
ein auge aus und er hängt sie dann
qualvoll
ob er dabei grausam mit gewissensbissen
erleidet dieser geiste perversität
sinniert der protagonist sei von der
philosophie nicht beachtet worden
die perversität aber sein ursprüngliches
grundvermögen eine boshafte vernunft die
kann für begrifflich als widersprüchlich
erachtet hatte ist nur poetisch magnet
bar
vielen dank